on the ground last night there were two
missile attacks and there were probably
these loitering Munitions that had come
from Iran this the Kamikaze drones and
they were in the cities of zapparista
and nicopol that we can see on the map
here but going to The Wider map
um and having a look across Ukraine as
to what's happening
um the Russians are having some success
in the center bit attacking into the
small town of bakmut that we can see
there
um uh but they're not making huge
amounts of progress in the north
um just north east of isium the
ukrainians are having some real success
but I think where things are beginning
to happen isn't Harrison done in the
South and that because it's on the
flanks of what the Russians are doing
back mode is putting them under some
very real pressure okay now let's talk
about these reservists Russia's saying
the enrollment's coming to an end
um how successful has it been how many
have been called up so far yes will
Vladimir Putin put 300 000 as a number
that's in there we've seen lots of
reports of the reservists coming out and
you know these are them trying to get
onto the trains the difference between
this picture and the reality is that
most of them seem to be having to buy
their own equipment and body armor which
is a very basic is the prices online
have gone through the roof apparently
and we're also coming into winter months
it's unlikely that a lot of these troops
are going to have the right winter gear
to be able to survive so they're being
put into the front line
260 odd thousand have been recruited
already but Putin says he's going to
ease that off 14 000 of red have already
gone into the the front land in the in
the combat areas but if they're not
being properly equipped and not been
properly trained they're not going to
have a great effect on the ground
right yeah and extraordinary contrast
with the pictures of young men trying to
flee as well isn't it so French
president macron has been speaking about
the situation in the last few days um
what has he been saying about Putin yeah
well he's he's really been responding to
what Putin's been saying and as we heard
from
um lukashenko earlier he's saying
Putin's most likely to go nuclear if
he's cornered Vladimir Putin has once
again rattled the nuclear cage with his
threats but unusually here
um president macron has come out and
said that France would not respond from
with a nuclear weapon if one was used
inside Ukraine now that has broken the
protocol that there is which is a
protocol of strategic ambiguity and so
that's you know the nuclear Powers don't
actually say what they will do and what
they won't do they don't put that hard
line
um in the sand so that the threat always
remains and that keeps that mutually
assured destruction piece that's
actually kept a piece for so many years
so far so we're now down to instead of
there being three nuclear Powers
potentially threatening Russia there's
only two the United States and the
United Kingdom right but as ever the UK
and the US will not draw those lines but
I think the UK is probably a little bit
focused on other things at the moment
okay as we've been discussing earlier in
the program okay well uh how about uh
let's talk about the United Kingdom
supports for Ukraine
um the head of the Armed Forces been
speaking as well he has and he put a
very clear statement about it yesterday
and I think this is probably because of
the political turmoil that we've got
remember in government we've got the
status quo with the secretary state for
defense but chief of the defense staff
Admiral radican was praising the
ukrainians for what they have achieved
and the defense they put in and
um he's he's also sort of reiterating
what the International Community is
doing when you look at it in keeping
International resolve in supporting
Ukraine sending a clear message to
Vladimir Putin a clear message to
lukashenko that Belarus stay out of it
because the International Community is
together as one on no matter what's
going on domestically in any particular
country